-Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
I appreciate it, guys.
Tomorrow is Halloween.
Yeah.
I read that this year some
of the most popular costumes
are Barbie, Spider-Man,
and Wednesday Addams,
while the least popular costume
is once again Sexy Ron DeSantis.
[ Laughter ]
Well, tomorrow New York City
will close down
a bunch of streets
for trick or treating.
Yep, they'll have candy,
decorations,
and maybe even a surprise visit
from "Doughnut Rat".
-Introducing "Doughnut Rat".
Viral video showing the rat
dragging a glazed donut
along the subway tracks
of a lower Manhattan station.
And check it out --
the rat even shares the treat
with his friend.
-Oh, my gosh. Yeah.
Halloween is almost here,
and tonight at the White House,
the Bidens hosted
trick or treaters.
Yeah, things got off
to a rough start
when Biden told the kid,
"Nice zombie costume."
The kid was like, "I'm you."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering ]
"Get out of here!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't think Biden's
quite up with the times.
Whenever he saw
a Taylor Swift costume,
he was like, "Greta Garbo?
Jean Harlow?"
[ Laughter ]
But it was adorable
when Biden asked kids,
"Who are you supposed to be?"
And a little less adorable
when he asked,
"And who am I again?"
But it was --
But it was nice
watching Biden hand out candy,
except when he reached
into the wrong pocket
and gave out a Flomax pill.
It's like, no, that's --
"You'll thank me
when you're older.
You'll thank me..."
So more political news.
Over the weekend,
Mike pence officially suspended
his 2024 presidential campaign.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which raises
an interesting question.
Can you stop something
that never started?
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that yesterday
former President Trump
held a campaign rally
in Sioux City, Iowa,
but he didn't seem to quite know
where he was.
Watch this.
-Well, thank you very much.
And a very big hello to a place
where we've done very well.
Sioux Falls. Thank you
very much, Sioux Falls.
[ Crowd boos ]
So Sioux City, let me ask you...
[ Laughter ]
"Wh-- Where was I?
Sioux city. Sioux city."
[ Laughs ]
Biden was like, "Someone
help that poor old man.
He's confused
and disoriented."
Even the biggest
Trump supporters are thinking,
"Maybe those gag orders
are a good idea."
Yeah, it makes sense
that he was confused.
It was the first time in months
he's been in a room
without a jury, so, yeah.
[ Audience oohs, laughs ]
-Joke?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Then Trump was like,
"And I love your founder,
the great Dr. Sue."
[ Laughter ]
"'Green Eggs and Ham',
the Grinch.
I love the Grinch."
You guys hear about this?
During a trip to China,
California Governor Gavin Newsom
played a basketball game
with some school kids.
Let's see how that went.
[ Indistinct chatter ]
Ooh, good spin. Yeah.
Hi-yah!
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
Yeah, not every day that you see
a governor
pick up a technical foul
against a 7 year old.
It's like...
[ Grunts ]
Oh, have you guys heard
about this Toyota recall?
Toyota? It's not good.
Check -- Check this out.
-A recall alert
for you this morning.
Toyota recalling
more than 750,000 SUVs.
Toyota says the SUVs have an
issue in the front lower bumper
that can cause the mounting tabs
to detach and fall off.
-What?
Oh, man. I drive a Toyota.
-Geez. Sorry, Tariq.
-I mean, it's not a big deal.
I mean, it's okay.
I still have my trusty
Honda Civic Hatchback.
-Oh.
-"Oh", what, Jimmy?
-Roll the clip.
-Honda is recalling more than
176,000 2022 to '24 Civic sedans
and hatchbacks.
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
-You don't have another way
to get around?
-I mean, I guess I could borrow
my friend's Tesla.
-A recall alert --
Tesla is recalling
tens of thousands
of its newer vehicles.
-Oh, come on.
-Yeah. I'm sorry, Tariq.
-Now, how am I supposed
to get to the store?
I still need to buy candy
for trick or treat tomorrow.
-You don't have anything
lying around the house?
-I could check
my kitten -- kitchen.
Excuse me, but all I have
is Best Buy Insignia
electric pressure cooker.
-Check your kitten -- kitchen's,
excuse me.
Best Buy says
that they are recalling
nearly a million Insignia
electric pressure cookers.
-Oh, come on.
-I'm s-- Tough luck.
Do you have anything else?
-I mean, I just bought
a brand-new
fyoot -- fruit purée pouches.
-The US Food and Drug
Administration is warning
not to buy a brand of fyoot --
fruit purée pouches.
[ Laughter ]
-What else do I even have?
Just lots of diced
yellow onions --
3 pound bags
and 8-ounce cumps -- cups.
-The recall alert
you need to know about.
-It covers some lots
of diced yellow onions --
3-pound bags
and 8-ounce cumps -- cups.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what? Fine!
-I'll just start handing out
my kids' old toys.
I mean, he can have
some Thomas & Friends --
you know, Wooden Rail --
Ray-uh Rail --
Troublesome Trucks and Crates.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
-The recall involves
roughly 21,000
of the Thomas & Friends
Wooden Rail-ray -- Railway
Troublesome Trucks and Crates.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a lot.
Can you believe this?
-Don't -- Don't encourage me.
-Do you believe this?
This is terrible.
-That's it, man!
-I'm sure there's something
that you can give
to trick-or-treaters.
-What do I even have left?
Dog food?!
-Well, what kind
of dog food is it?
-Well, it's TFP Nutrition's
Retriever All Life Stages
Mini Chunk Micro Chicken Recipe
Dry Dog Food.
[ Laughter ]
-My goodness. That is a title.
-The FDA is recalling
TFP Nutrition's
Retriever All Life Stages
Mini Chunk Chicken Recipe
Dry Dog Food.
My goodness. That is a title.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I'm done.
-Tariq Trotter, everybody.
Tariq Trotter.
-That's...
♪♪
That's a lot of stuff
to go through.
[ Applause ]
-I feel bad for him.
-He had a tough night. Yeah.
-Oh, man.
-I got some movie news.
This weekend,
"Five Nights at Freddy's"
won the box office,
bringing in $130 million.
-Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was so huge that they're
already planning a sequel,
and it looks even scarier.
Check this out.
-They survived
"Five Nights at Freddy's,"
but this time
they're pushed to the edge.
Their sanity is tested.
And no one will escape.
Next fall, it's...
"Six Hours on Spirit Airlines."
[ Cabin bell dings ]
-[ Screams ]
-Only supposed to be 45 minutes.
"Six hours?
Let me off this thing."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, speaking of
Spirit Airlines,
they just announced that
they're suspending training
for new pilots and flight
attendants until further notice.
I get if you have to do that,
but why announce it?
We have a great show.
Give it up for the Roots,
everybody. Come on, now.
-♪ She wanna know
if we can be together ♪
♪ Even if it ain't
gonna be forever ♪
♪ It can only be for one night ♪
♪ The only thing I ever loved
in my life was the mic ♪
♪ Uh-huh, come on ♪
-Whoo!
What a show we have
for you tonight.
He's currently starring
in the play "Waiting for Godot"
at the Polonsky Shakespeare
Theater in Brooklyn.
Michael Shannon is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some very talented people here
tonight.
She is a Tony winner
who you can see in
"Sweeney Todd" on Broadway.
Annaleigh Ashford is joining us.
-So funny.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mind-blowing.
-Did you see --
-I would put that performance
up with a Nathan Lane
or a Martin short.
That funny. Unbelievable.
-She was like
Lucille Ball funny.
-Crazy.
-When she goes down the stairs.
-Down the stairs? Oh, my God.
-That's the funniest thing ever.
-Got to go see it.
-Speaking of funny...
-Who?
-Jesus Trejo is here!
Very funny comedian.
[ Chuckles ]
"Practicing?"
That's his new special
on YouTube.
Well, guys, it's Monday night,
and you know what that means.
It's "Tonight Show"
Trivia Night.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ "Tonight Show" Trivia Night ♪
-Yeah. Fun. I love trivia.
Higgins, you want to explain
how this works?
-I would love to.
Yes, Jimmy,
to test your knowledge
on a wide variety of topics,
I'm going to be asking you
a series of trivia questions,
and all you have to do
is answer them correctly.
-Alright. This is easy.
I love trivia. Let's do this.
-Ready? First question.
-Um, Fort Knox.
[ Buzzer ]
-Ooh, close.
The deodorant aisle at CVS.
[ Laughter ]
So close, so close.
Okay. Ready?
-Easy. Rice Krispies.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, no. Incorrect.
Joe Biden when he stands up.
[ Laughter ]
Almost. You almost got it.
Almost got it.
Alright, Jimmy, ready?
-Yep.
-"What is the meaning of life?"
[ Buzzer ]
-Judges?
No. "Why is pickleball
so popular?"
[ Laughter ]
For centuries!
-I don't know why.
-For hundreds of years,
they've been trying
to answer that.
Alright, Jimmy,
you'll get this one.
-X.
[ Buzzer ]
-Wrong. Twitter.
They call it Twitter.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ah, yeah.
-Close. You almost got it.
You almost got it.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay. Ready?
You're going to get this one.
I know.
-Mm-hmm.
-What's the most common place
for senior citizens --
where do they go
to enjoy their golden years?
Senior citizens.
Where do they go?
-Florida.
[ Buzzer ]
-No. Congress. Congress.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Preach!"
-Preach.
-That was my political --
That's from my stand-up act.
-Your stand-up act, by the way.
Yeah, I got to make it.
-You got to go see it.
I take a newspaper, I just riff.
-No, I'm busy.
-Oh, really, what are you doing?
-Very busy.
-What about tomorrow?
-That's Halloween.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Alright. Ready?
-I love this.
-What is the hardest thing
on Earth?
Don't get sexual.
-What is the hardest thing?
-The hardest thing on Earth.
It's a family show.
-I'm not getting sexual.
-I don't know. A family show.
-What is the hardest thing
on Earth?
-Yes, what is
the hardest thing on Earth?
-Diamond.
-Wrong!
[ Buzzer ]
-Canceling a gym membership.
-Oh, yeah, that's true.
That is right. That is correct.
-One more.
-That is right.
-Okay.
-This one's worth
a million points.
-Mm-hmm.
-So if you win this one,
you win the whole thing.
Ready?
-Yep.
-This year's NFL MVP.
-Taylor Swift.
-Yes!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
That is all the time we have.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show,"
everybody!